so like my mind went to the whole you
know as young girls we grew up on Disney
we know about the prince charming and
this is this and this kind of sets our
ideology as far as our husband or what
we want from a man flip that on its head
I'm not too sure if it's like that in
the States but in the UK there's this
thing of I don't know if anyone
remembers being in primary school you
know if a boy pushed you over or teased
you or was horrible to you it meant that
he did that because he fancied you and I
feel like somewhere along the lines as
we've grown up and as we've become women
there is this oh if he's being mean to
me if he's ignoring me obviously it
makes you want to chase them more
because maybe psychologically you feel
like he wants you and that's why he's
being mean to you